- Let's consider what a
generic business model
might look like for a firm
pursuing a differentiation strategy.
As we know, the essence of
a differentiation strategy
is the idea of increasing
customer willingness
to pay for something
that they value highly.
It could be a branded product,
an exceptionally high-quality product,
the latest piece of technology, etc.
What would a differentiation-based
business model look like?
Again, you could begin anywhere.
Let's start with premium prices.
Premium prices obviously
generate high margins.
These higher margins allow for investments
in different forms of uniqueness.
That could be additional brand marketing
which could induce higher
levels of consumer loyalty.
It could be increased investments in R&D
to produce new, more innovative,
higher-quality products
which are sought after
by loyal customers.
It could be any other investment
that leads to improvements
in the firm's reputation
which increase consumer loyalty.
Consumer loyalty in turn
leads to an increased willingness to pay,
which in turn allows the
firm to charge premium prices
and a virtuous cycle is created.
There are an infinite
number of business models,
but all innovative business models
come from strategists
using their three sights;
foresight, insight, and cross-sight.
They're created by business leaders
who look at their value
chains and see new ways
and interesting ways
of combining activities
to produce superior returns.
To quote Joan Magretta,
who was a specialist
on business models;
"Today, business model and strategy
"are among the most
sloppily-used terms in business.
"They're often stretched
to mean everything
"and end up meaning nothing."
What we know for sure
is that successful businesses
must have tightly-linked,
coherent business models
and good strategies.